millones de personas vuelven a arabia
saudita para lapidar al un acto
simbólico que consiste en lanzar piedras
a tres muros de hormigón y que en el
islam representa vencer la tentación
casi hemos terminado con los rituales
tenemos un sentimiento muy agradable y
esperamos que todos los musulmanes
puedan hacer el hadj este ritual hace
parte de la peregrinación del hash que
este año contó con una multitudinaria
participación tras dos años de
restricciones destinadas a frenar el
cobre 19 y también marca el inicio de la
alergia cuando los musulmanes de todo el
mundo sacrifican animales y a menudo
reparten la carne entre los pobres el
evento reunió a millones de fieles en
territorios del mundo islámico como
jerusalén gaza egipto o siria pero lo
que se supone debía ser un festejo en
abundancia este año coincide con una
fuerte alza de los precios de los
alimentos afganistán con una economía
débil y un contexto convulso es un
ejemplo de ello muchos de mis amigos no
podían permitirse comprar ganado y
regresaron a casa con las manos vacías
en comparación con años anteriores
estamos experimentando miseria y pobreza
ahora guix o en líbano ya golpeado por
fuertes crisis económicas y políticas
dónde está la atmósfera del aire la
mayoría de la gente no trajo nada a sus
familias y es que a la devastación
causada por la pandemia se suma la
guerra en ucrania que de seguir
prolongándose según la onu provocará un
infierno en la tierra a causa de la
hambruna